more than 12,000 firefighters are
battling the nine major wildfires in
California this morning officials warned
state resources are stretched thin a
group of fires known as the Mendocino
complex has burned more than 30,000
acres in Mendocino and lake counties the
flames forced the entire town of Lake
Port to evacuate midday aviary al is in
nearby Yukiya Media good morning good
morning these fires are being blamed
right now for injuring seven
firefighters and destroying six
structures including the one that we are
standing in this morning and all of this
since it began last Friday now fire
officials are saying that the weather
conditions are improving in the area
which is helping firefighters get a
handle on these fires and slowing the
fires spread but there are other fires
around the state that are proving to be
difficult to contain right now
the Ferguson wildfire near Yosemite
National Park is still burning after
more than two weeks on Sunday a second
firefighter died battling the flames
when he was struck by a falling tree
seven other firefighters have been
injured in that fire and officials
announced at Yosemite Valley in the
heart of the National Park will remain
closed until Friday at the earliest now
right now while weather conditions are
favorable in medicine oh and in Lake
County there is no guarantee that will
stick around in fact they are expecting
temperatures to hit triple digits in
this area later today which could prove
difficult for these fire crews Nora but
a thank you and we're going to continue
to follow these fast-moving fires
tonight Jeff Glor will anchor the CBS
Evening News from California